you just turned 18 I did hello yeah
eighteens a big one especially in London
especially at home it's why is it a
bigger deal in London than it is here
you can drink you can drink at 18 you
can as it should be and you are now more
popular than anyone running for
president yes so you you you can drink
and so what's that's got to be
frustrating because you finally you turn
18 you can drink you can have some fun
and where are you you're in America I
know it's a it's tough earlier today I
was a I was a I was that bar and I was
approached by the bus and Andy actually
that's me
Oh young man you like a soda I saw
smiles like please and just held it in
because it's so heartbreaking to have to
not be able to buy a drink yeah you'd
think that if you're a British citizen
wait you could drink at the Embassy I
bet you could you could get to then on
sacred soil you could get trashed do you
know do you know Elvis's I'll get don't
find out we got to find out where there
anyone in the crowd know where the
British should be the great lengths to
go you've got a great length I will fly
you there we're gonna get you with
Jack's good we're gonna get you there
you could just pay some shady person
outside of a liquor store to buy you
some half after the show I'll take you
you're over 21 he does this for another
little thief I'm he's Davey right wasn't
that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]